messieurs dames comment allez-vous moi
ça va extrêmement bien sachez que ça
fait une heure que la caméra est allumée
et que je ne tourne pas j'ai traîné sur
youtube je saurais pas vous citer ne
serait ce qu'une seule vidéo de celle
que je viens de regarder je suis
tellement pas productive quand il fait 0
degré d or c'est horrible en revanche je
suis toujours capable de trouver des
excuses
aujourd'hui on va traîner sur la semry
dit rassurant mais voilà larmes ont tous
un peu de confiance il fait très froid
on n'est pas long d'après interactions
sociales ça pue un peu la merde
finalement la ville à se sevrer dit
'j'aimerais pas être dedans
vous savez ces trucs que tu tentes au
quotidien tu tentes des choses et des
fois ça passe pas bah y en a ça passe
pas donc ils sont des gains mais en plus
ils ont été filmés et ça ça fait chier
ces gens là nous on adore évidemment
bref bienvenue sur trois est de la tête
exemple tout de suite avec une première
vidéo il ya une tentative de rendre sa
baby proof
waouh le truc est tellement fixé qui
soulève la chaise wahou
[Musique]
non c'est vraiment du foutage de gueule
mais c'est pas qu'ils ont pas pensé au
petit doigt de bébés qui s'insèrent
partout à l'express n'as-tu pas route il
ya eu une tentative de vider des
bouteilles d'alcool confisqués comment
tu peut échouer oh quel régal et disent
rien les pauvres dont j'ai de la peine
ils peuvent rien faire contre ces gens
qui veulent faire la fête et s'amuser à
une époque on pouvait excusez moi il y à
une tentative d'interdire l'entrée si tu
ne porte pas de masque
bah tiens donc à vous dit pas grand
chose là les cuistots à j'aurais
tellement rien dit mon garage aurait
fait ma pizza tranquillement sans rien
dire mais j'aurais pensé très fort il y
ait eu tentative de se gratter au nom
c'est génial j'ai déjà compris
qu'est-ce qui le coup et qu'on prend à y
croire vraiment qui s'est gratté ses
deux il fait vraiment le mouv où il se
laisse entre les orteils après achat
d'or adorable ce chat vraiment adorable
il ya une tentative de manger un grain
de raisin attentes s'entend c'est de la
smr de l'apa il ya des lapins youtuber
qui fondait sa mère pour d'autres lapins
c'est incroyable j'avais pas vu ce qui
se passe mais c'est déjà incroyable
[Musique]
trouvez-moi la chaîne youtube de ce
lapin s'il vous plaît trouvez-moi ssh
and switch on est à touba on attendait
par contre on est d'accord qui est un
mec sur terre là il a acheté un micro un
lapin et un grain de raisin et il s'y
dit j'ai un combo smr c'est incroyable
je suis millionnaire en vrai il y à une
tentative d'écraser la tête d'un enfant
dans son gâteau d'anniversaire
ah bon la classique on se souvient de
l'astuce de l'assiette qu'on met entre
son visage et le gâteau au dernier
moment si vous avez un entourage de gros
chiens voilà souvenez-vous de cette
astuce est alors qu'est-ce qui a raté il
retire les bougies lui ont demandé de
retirer les bougies or il est mignon je
suis fatigué aujourd'hui tous mes
extermine démons bien il a fêté son
animal au pit à lille ont attrapé son
grand cauchy là ils l'ont expulsé quand
le set de table c'est terrible ils lui
ont dit de retirer les bougies ça c'est
vraiment vous êtes grillés quand vous
faites ça retire les bougies pour
quelles raisons non non mais j'ai la
juste retire c'est vrai vous êtes
vraiment gré quand vous dites cette
phrase de gamme et ceci dit vous pensé à
la sécurité c'est bien il ya une
tentative d'arrêter le train alors à
j'adore il ya trop de vidéos comme ça
qu'ils traînent de chats qui sont sur
des parcours de trains miniatures que
j'affectionne particulièrement comme
vous le savez alors attendez mission
pour crimes au river retrouver cette
vidéo ça va lui prendre un mois d'accord
c'est reiniche il ya des mecs ont des
parcours de train comme ça donc vous
savez mais qui met des caméras dessus et
du coup quand leur chat se balade dans
le parcours on dirait une sorte de
godzilla parce qu'on se rend plus compte
des proportions direct le chèque géant à
d'extrêmes maintenant vous allez voir
c'est incroyable
[Musique]
alors je vous ai pas régalé là il ya une
tentative de prendre des photos de ce
que tu bois en réalité virtuelle c'est
parce que je pense c'est parce que je
pense elle est là elle est là
l'évolution messe pascale je suis désolé
je suis méprisant ça se fait pas de se
moquer mais la belle a quand même c'est
un level frérot c'est ouf mec je veux la
vidéo du moment où elle rentre chez elle
pour raconter à sa famille jean
l'expérience de fuchs était la réalité
virtuelle et où elle prend son appareil
elle va dans la photothèque la leur
montre elle se rend compte de sa bêtise
mais c'est trop tard oh non c'est
terrible c'est mignon il ya eu tentative
d'écrire il est très court le titre ça
ça va être excellent ok
[Musique]
non non ça tue le cadreur a dû lui dire
faites semblant d'écrire un truc là
c'est juste qu'on ait deux ou trois
plans de coupe là pendant le
documentaire et au lieu d'écrire un truc
pour de faux elle n'a pas écrit elle a
fait semblant d'écrire au c'est magique
quel moment de solitude ça a tenté de
faire le littéraire aucun mot anglais ne
contient un double aux as par good
prouvez moi le contraire book
tu devrais essayer d'en lire 1 j'adore
il ya des mecs qui vive pour ça ils
rentrent du travail soit un peu fatiguée
un peu aigri séjour n'est pas top et il
tombe sur une image c'est un peu bête et
ils envoient leur punch et je serai
ferme le pc comme ça après ils vont
faire des fajitas et sentent bien ils
sont prêts à attaquer la dure journée du
lendemain
j'adore il y à une tentative de passer
de la parole aux actes
oh
elle va te fumer
k
elle la déglinguer attendait le mec a
tellement d'ego il est tellement
misogynes que même quand il se fait
clairement massacrés par cette brave
dame
il veut pas taper pour dire qu'il a
perdu il devrait faire s'évanouir ce qui
est 400 fois plus humiliant on est
d'accord au nom lui claque le cul comme
un enfant après collier mais du tac et
se fait [ __ ] non excusez moi mais
c'est quoi ce sport de combat on se met
des petites claques humiliante sur la
peau là qui font ce bruit c'est ça que
millions ça a tenté de vendre ses huiles
essentielles vous voulez voir quel type
du naturel je transporte avec moi et
pourquoi non
on s'en fout tu le dégage toi et tes
produits de merde c'est d'une cruauté
les sondages un star à chaque fois que
j'en fais je suis pas bien j'ai trop
peur des fois j'en les milliers de
personnes qui voient là stories soient
concertées pour appuyer sur le même
bouton c'est trop humiliant c'est je
suis sûr ils avaient préparé le code
promo il avait tout sous la main à
l'esav est gage olala ça a tenté de flex
avec un gun
il va tuer c'est baptiste mai aux
etats-unis nous il fait un petit feu de
camp dans sa chambre comme ça à la
france la normandie fait un peu frais le
petit feu lui et tire avec un flingue
mec
imagine tu as mis un être humain au
monde je t'en occuper 19 ans et tout
pour qu'un samedi à 14h30 entendent un
coup de feu dans sa chambre mais merde
je peux définitivement pas d'enfant
d'accord au un écureuil kit est un chien
une belle phrase à temps il ya un gland
qui vient de sortir de sa fourrure oh je
viens de comprendre aussi à 12 m et ça
je le sais grâce à l'âge de glace à 0
blague en fait l'écureuil il a voulu
enterrer son gland dans le pelage du
chien j'avais oublié qu'il faisait ça la
patience du chien j'adore ça a tenté de
recréer une photo de famille mignonne
[Musique]
mais déjà comment ne pas être gigaba la
neige commence d'aaron n'est pas julien
mal à l'aise excusez moi mais c'est
incroyable ça a tenté de trahir coca
cola à elle est reconnue cette histoire
moi je la mets au même niveau que les
légendes sur marilyn manson à l'époque
vous savez j'en refais au concert il
envoyé des chars dans le public qui
s'était fait retirer des côtes pour pour
moi ce même level
il y aurait en 2006 un employé de coca
cola qui serait allé voir pepsi en leur
disant les gars j'ai la recette de coca
je vous donne le secret et pepsi plutôt
que d'accepter sa demande serait allé
voir coca pour leur dire les gaillards
vos employés veut faire fuiter la
recette attention c'est 100% une légende
créé par pepsi pour les rendre un petit
peu sympa etc
qu'est ce qu'ils sont forts en comme ces
américains ça a tenté d'avoir une fête
de révélations du sexe du bébé
voilà ma traduction et boeuf au oui je
sais aussi dépit d'attaqués fois
[Applaudissements]
on sera pas il est né hermaphrodite du
coup bravo quelle horreur oh non ça a
tenté de montrer les vêtements dans des
tailles très large pour mettre à l'aise
des personnes de tout poids devant c'est
au riz ils ont mis un bas de mannequins
par jambes assez horrible j'ai jamais vu
un truc qui part d'une si bonne
intention et qui finalement fait si mal
ou peut-être ils vendent des pantalons
que tu peux partager avec un ami non ils
sont ratés ont fait complice et des gens
voient ça a tenté de faire descendre le
chat du comptoir
il va le défoncer
aurais tu sais quoi ce chat mon gars ils
ont évolué ça y est l'eau s'est terminé
0 peur y en a qui disent il faut leur
souffler dessus quand c'est comme ça
mais après tu es sur ton canapé tu
respires un peu fort parce qu'il ya une
scène d'action dans ton film est
touchant de grippe le visage parce qu'il
a peur c'est pas le meilleur truc je
vous le dis et bien messieurs dames
j'espère que c'est vrai dit vous appelez
moi je trouve assez que celles en suis
là y'a un peu tout il ya aussi beaucoup
d'image ou c'est du texte j'ai essayé
d'éviter le plus possible et tous et du
texte parce que c'est un peu relou de
l'homme
allons-nous tenter des choses dans les
24 prochaines heures cheyrou je vous
cache pas là j'ai plus envie de tenter
quoi que ce soit je me retrouvais dans
la vidéo d'un mec qu'on rigole ça à me
saouler savons nous couler à bientôt
prenez soin de vous j'ai fait un geste
de la main pour cette fin un peu ringard
[Musique]